hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein ganz besonderes
rezept denn der murat hat heute
geburtstag und jetzt gedacht ich
überrasche ihn heute mit einer leckeren
torten und habe mir überlegt ich mache
heute eine kaffee torte denn er mag ganz
gerne kaffee krems und kaffee joghurt
ich glaube sein lieblings er ist auch
dieses konzert gibt es oder so irgendwie
so joghurt mit mokka geschmack und da
schwärmt da immer davon
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich kann ihnen
wahrscheinlich eine richtig große freude
machen mit einem leckeren kaffee kuchen
oder einer kaffee torte der murat ist
heute übrigens nicht mehr dabei denn es
soll eine überraschung werden und am
ende des videos hoffe ich dass ich ihnen
dann noch in die küche bekommen
vielleicht vor die kamera ich weiß es
nicht
mal schauen was er macht auf jeden fall
zeige ich euch jetzt ganz frisch die
zutaten für den teig und später dann
wird die creme ich brauche zwei eier 100
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
vanille extrakt hier habe ich 100
milliliter starken kaffee 100 milliliter
öl ein sonnenblumenöl 150 g mehl 50 g
speisestärke zehn gramm kakaopulver und
15 teelöffel backpulver und falls ihr
euch fragt der moralisch nicht da wäre
steht jetzt hinter der kamera also der
murat findet er mich nicht mehr nur
alleine
ich habe ja auch zwei kameras und aber
mein tipp stelle ich euch beieinander
auf jeden fall wird's heute networking
habe ich eier und zucker in der
rührschüssel und gips holz mit dazu und
die vanille
und es wird jetzt schön cremig gerührt
und wenn die masse dann richtig weiß
cremig ist gebe ich noch die
flüssigkeiten dazu also öl und kaffee
wer möchte könnte zum beispiel auch im
café liga mit dazu geben bei denen dass
ich weg ganz kurz einrühren
und die trockenen zutaten werden jetzt
hinein gesiebt
jetzt werden die auch ganz kurz noch
eingerührt
und jetzt will ich den teig in eine
vorbereitete backform und zwar habe ich
den bug rahmen auf 26 cm eingestellt und
habe den mit backpapier bereits
eingeschlagen und den ofen habe ich
jetzt auch schon bereits vorgeheizt und
zwar auf 175 grad ober und unterhitze
und da wird der teig geht es für
ungefähr 20 bis 25 minuten gebacken
es macht auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe und lass ihn dann komplett
abkühlen
der teichboden ist jetzt abgekühlt ich
habe ihn einfach hier auch so ein
brocken gitter gesetzt und jetzt lese
ich einmal den springform rand oder
denkbar kramen dran
jetzt werde ich den teig mit seinem
paten retter weg
und schneit jetzt oben sonne ganz ganz
dünne schicht weg also wirklich ganz
dünn da nehme ich jetzt hier die
unterste einstellung von der torten säge
und die obere schicht die nehme ich
jetzt hier runter und zerkrümelt die
gleiche kommt dann nämlich später noch
mal oben drauf jetzt kann ich schon mal
den taten boden auf einem kuchen auf
einer kuchen platte anrichten
einfach drauf platzieren jetzt setzt
sich da einen tortenring außen rum jetzt
könnt ihr an der stelle wenn ihr möchtet
den tortenboden auch gerne beträufeln
entweder mit bisschen kaffee oder zum
beispiel mit einem café liegt dann wird
auch der kuchen bisschen saftiger das
stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite und
bereitet schon mal die creme zu da hab
ich mir jetzt die zutaten schon mal
gerichtet und zwar brauche ich dafür 250
gramm mascarpone 200 milliliter sahne 60
gramm puderzucker
ich habe ich 20 km kaffeepulver und zwar
ist es wirklich so ein pulver also so
ein löslicher kaffee
ich habe vier teelöffel sommerbad etwas
vanille extrakt und später brauche ich
dann noch zwei esslöffel zucker 50 gramm
mandelsplitter und 40 gramm schock
streuseln bereite ich erstmal die creme
zu dafür kommt jetzt die mascarpone in
eine rührschüssel da gebe ich direkt
puderzucker mitteilen
extrakt das passt allzu gut
es gibt gleich auch noch bestimmt mit
auf die strecke habe ich zum vergessen
herauszustellen dann das kaffeepulver
und das lasse jetzt ganz kurz einmal
verrühren
jetzt gebe ich jedoch die sahne mit rein
die muss natürlich schön kalt sein dem
oscar krone auf und gebe jetzt auch
gleich sein apartment rein und lassen
eben steif schlagen
do
die fertige creme fühle ich dann jetzt
in den top bringen also direkt auf den
tortenboden wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
jetzt auch zum beispiel ein paar bananen
auf den teig legen dann hab da noch ein
bisschen frucht mit dabei aber ich mache
der morath jetzt eine ganz normale
kaffeepott ohne irgendwie schnickschnack
und wenn ihr übrigens kein kaffeepulver
habt müsste halt auf espresso zum
beispiel zurückgreifen
mit kaffee granulat geht nicht dass den
müsst ihr jetzt vorher dann auch
auflösen mit bisschen wasser
aber weil er seiner partei nutzt geht es
dann auf jeden fall auch also wir dann
auch schön fest statt nur bisschen mehr
sein
die torte habe ich jetzt kurz kalt
gestellt und kann jetzt schon mal die
streusel vorbereiten und dafür habe ich
mir schon mal eine pfanne erhitzt gibt
da die mandeln mit rein und dem zucker
und es weder trainierten bisschen
karamellisiert
einfach immer schön rühren und aufpassen
dass es nicht anbrennt
und dann gebe ich die karamellisierte
mandeln offenen teller wäre ich jetzt in
der pfanne lassen würde würden sie
nämlich noch weiter karamell gesehen und
eventuell verbrennen einfach so ein
bisschen verteilen damit so schnell
akteuren da müsste auch echt aufpassen
dass sich nicht verbrennt
ich habe mit einem spruchband
die lassen jetzt hier ganz kurz stehen
und kann schon mal hier die kuchen reste
zerkrümeln ganz alleine den händen
da kommen jetzt noch die schokostreusel
mit rein und eben ein bisschen sind also
das mache ich jetzt ja so ein bisserl
sind mit rein so ein viertel teelöffel
ungefähr wartet jetzt und ich glaube der
kuchen mit einem rad richtig gut
schmecken
mal das café mit rillen stimmt mit drin
und jetzt auch noch karamell und es sind
so seine favoriten würde ich noch
überhaupt dann sehen dass jetzt die
mandeln noch ganz kurz abkühlen und
sobald die kalt sind geht es dann gleich
weiter
die mandeln sind jetzt abgekühlt und
jetzt könnt ihr die nehmen er hat auch
diesen richtig knusprig die kommen jetzt
einfach so zerkleinert mit in diese
sträuben
jetzt kommt auch gerade der moratti tür
ein als herz gebrochen
juli mit der arbeit
jetzt weiß ich dass nach trotz nur
gebacken oder auch gekocht auch gekocht
gibt gleich was zu essen
und jetzt kommen diese streusel direkt
auf den kuchen darf durch bisschen zu
früh dran
ich wollte eigentlich schon fertig haben
also ich weiß nicht was jetzt gerade
macht aber aber ich kannst du vorstellen
hat das café zu tun
gewünscht ich hab mir eine freude mit
einem kaffee kuchen
ich schenke dir nichts an der
kaffeemaschine
dann hab ich was zuvor hatte sie schon
richtig gut aus und es riecht auch sehr
lecker aber ich stelle die torte jetzt
gleich noch mal kalt bevor ihr sie
anschneiden einfach damit sie noch mal
lächeln fest wird und ich hab jetzt hier
noch so ein paar schoko wohnen also
dieser show kaffeebohnen und die kommen
jetzt hier auch die kann man ja so in
der buck abteilung kaufen und ich hab
das jetzt so ganz einfach gewählt weil
der mut hat eigentlich mehr so der fan
von einfachen kuchen und torten ist also
mit ihnen kann man jetzt mit seiner
front orte nicht wirklich überraschen
oder beeindrucken weil für ihn ist es
praktisch sein und gut schmecken und
deswegen geht eben dieser kaffee tee und
billig muss es sein sagte michael stich
preiswert und schnell vor allem also
dass ich jetzt echt mehr ganz schnelle
torte und ich verteile jetzt hier noch
ganz kurz darauf stellte noch mal im
kühlschrank und schneiden wir den kuchen
gleich an
zusammen jetzt lese ich kurz den torten
rahmen
jetzt nachdem morath probieren und
seiner geburtstagstorte
ich bin schon gespannt also ich finde
sie riecht schon mal richtig lecker ist
auch toll gewesen wäre wenn du anstatt
dieser dieser show conan wilder richtige
kaffeebohnen liegt ist sie auf den
kaffeebohnen zu beißen
manchmal wenn ich irgendwo hingehe in
den supermarkt dann und da kann ich auch
den kaffee sehr gemein
da glaube ich die ganze zeit erfolgt
nach monat
das hat mich toll ins auge fahrig lieb
so einfach stoppen
wirklich ich weiß es nicht kaffee dazu
oder also mehr ein espresso oder ich bin
gespannt wer dir schmeckt chef freundin
schon mal probiert sie schmeckt sehr
nach kaffee das heißt wenn man es nicht
so sein möchte muss man weniger
kaffeebohnen vornehmen
göttlich einfach genial statt 20
vielleicht wird die hälfte nehmen oder
ein bisschen helfen nur zehn gramm
kaffee mit nur zehn gramm kapitän aber
ob dies so richtig knusprig der boden
ist so richtig locker ich hab eigentlich
alles mit dabei was du magst ein
bisschen schokolade bisschen kaffee
bisschen karamell vanille zimt
eigentlich und dabei wie die schneekoppe
damals genau wie ich einen wirklich auch
eine sehr einfache torte also der teig
ist super schnell zubereitet sehr
schnell gebacken schnell abgekühlt und
ich denke insgesamt habe ich jetzt
vielleicht von anfang bis zum schluss
zwei stunden gebraucht also wirklich gar
nicht lange
das heißt wenn ihr mal spontan besuch
bekommt also spontan angekündigt und ihr
wisst es zwei stunden vorher bescheid
dann können auf jeden fall dieses buch
bringt kenntnisse karamellisierte
mandelsplitter bei uns ich freue mich
dass er den schwenk und ich würde sagen
den rest stehe ich jetzt wieder einen
kühlschrank den später kommen noch meine
eltern vorbei möglich gehen ja sagte ok
dann freute sich genießt du mal weiter
und wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf meinem blog de
ich werde den kuchen morath café torte
taufen
bis zum nächsten runde sind danke
einfach
hat ja noch nicht mal ab